Chris Evans and Jenny slate hit the red
carpet at the LA premiere of their new
film gifted Tuesday night the exes
smiled big as they posed next to each
other for photos they even shared in
adorable laughs seeing Chris again here
tonight how will that be for you guys
very thun's be great she's the best I
think your niece may be gifted I
promised my sister I'd give Mary a
normal life and then she's got to be
here everybody is talking about what a
special movie this is what will you take
away from the experience of working on
it I got to work with some really really
seasoned actors you know getting to go
to work with Octavia Spencer with Chris
Evans McKenna grace is like a little
nugget of gold yeah so you know
professionally it was just a great
learning experience you mentioned Chris
what was it like working with him oh
he's just an absolutely really giving
performer and a wonderful actor yes it's
delight total delight and what does it
feel like to hear that kind of praise
from your co-stars that they just love
working with you well it's nice I would
send the same praise right back at them
they're just as phenomenal and wonderful
people and incredibly talented
performers and lucky to call them
friends what's your famous fear that our
really amazing
ah she's bossy I've heard that
[Music]
you